[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
au sommaire aujourd'hui la guinée à la
fin de son ultime mandat le président de
ce pays propose de changer la
constitution un projet qui fait sortir
les guinéens dans la rue tandis que sur
le terrain la crise politique prend de
l'ampleur la communauté internationale
montre plutôt de la retenue alors
comment la guinée reçoit-elle cette
réforme controversée le 29 janvier alpha
condé publie les règles du référendum
constitutionnel
en plus d'une vingtaine d'articles
document fixe les conditions de la
campagne électorale est décrit le
processus du scrutin
la tenue du référendum est fixée au 1er
mars 2020 pourtant l'opposition veut
coûte que coûte empêcher cette réforme
de la constitution dont ils prétendent
qu'elle n'est qu'une manoeuvre pour
ouvrir la voie à un troisième mandat du
président condé pour cela les forces
politiques d'opposition appelle sans
cesse à des manifestations le
gouvernement
elles réagissent souvent par la force le
bilan est lourd avec des dizaines de
morts et des centaines d'arrestations
cette crise n'a pas manqué d'attirer
l'attention de la communauté
internationale
l'onu l'union européenne la cedeao appel
à l'organisation d'élections
transparentes sans pourtant m alpha
condé en cause la même position est
adoptée par les états unis la france
elle se dit sceptique quant à l'idée du
référendum
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette réforme
constitutionnelle au coeur de la crise
politique guinéenne
c'est le blitz à quelques mois de la fin
de son deuxième mandat alpha condé
confirme les rumeurs qui couraient
depuis longtemps à savoir qu'un
référendum constitutionnel serait en
cours de préparation
cependant il n'est pas question de
modifier le texte actuel condé veut
carrément adopter une nouvelle
constitution
ce n'est qu'un cycle il pourrait
échapper une disposition de la
constitution actuelle qui stipule
l'interdiction de réviser le nombre et
la durée des mandats présidentiels
avec l'adoption de cette nouvelle
constitution certains opposants le
soupçonne de vouloir remettre les
compteurs à zéro et de s'octroyer le
droit de se représenter
la durée de ces mandats passerait alors
de 5 à 6 ans l'autre changements prévus
concernent l'extension des prérogatives
présidentielles selon le texte de la
réforme le président nommerait le
président de la cour constitutionnelle
et puis il ya d'autres modifications
notamment dans les domaines judiciaire
et sociale la peine de mort seraient
abolis l'école deviendrait gratuite et
l'assurance de l'état serait accordée
aux personnes âgées et handicapées
la guinée s'enfonce dans une crise
politique d'une gravité exceptionnelle
depuis le mois d'octobre un intense
mouvement de contestation agite le pays
en cause le référendum constitutionnel
initié par le président du pays alpha
condé à quelques mois de la fin de son
second mandat il propose d'adopter une
nouvelle constitution qui pourrait
potentiellement lui permettre de rester
à la tête du pays pendant encore douze
ans une perspective qui n'est
certainement pas du goût de l'opposition
les forces politiques anti condé se
réunissent pour des actions communes
avec un objectif bien précis empêcher à
tout prix la tenue du scrutin afin
d'exercer plus de pression sur le
pouvoir elle lance un appel à des
organisations internationales parmi
lesquelles la cedeao l'union africaine
l'union européenne les nations unies
mais leurs réponses se limite à des
expressions d'inquiétude et des appels à
la retenue la france elle est presque la
seule à avoir fermement condamné les
actions d'alpha condé comment la
diplomatie française
justifie t'elle sa position pourquoi les
pays de la région et vit-il de critiquer
le président guinéen
enfin quel est son bilan dix ans après
son accession au pouvoir
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons hamza de boukari à barra
professeur à l'école politique africaine
de paris secrétaire général de la ligue
panafricaine humeau ja monsieur boukari
à barra bonjour bonjour une nouvelle
constitution permettrait donc alpha
condé de briguer un troisième mandat
pour l'instant il n'a pourtant pas
clarifié ses intentions pour les
prochaines élections
cependant pensez vous qu'il avait
indéniablement se présenter aux
présidentielles si la nouvelle
constitution est finalement adopté non
un faconde et a été dans l'opposition
pendant pendant 50 ans en 2010 il a été
le premier président élu
démocratiquement de la république de
guinée il a été réélu en 2015
techniquement parlant il ne devait faire
que deux mandats mais cependant les
les rumeurs et des manoeuvres et des
procédures qui tendent vers la mise en
place d'une réforme de la constitution
il permettra effectivement de se
représenter pour un voire deux mandats
supplémentaires de six ans renouvelable
et on est quand même dans un cas de
figure où il est peu probable que un
chef d'état en exercice fasse autant
d'efforts pour ne pas se représenter
donc il ya quand même un fort climat de
suspicion sur la volonté de alpha condé
de se présenter pour un troisième mandat
en sachant que c'est une pratique qui
n'est pas limitée à la guinée on a
d'autres cas dont l'afrique de l'ouest
de président qui souhaite faire un
troisième mandat et qui met en place les
modalités de le faire donc il ya quand
même je dirais un certain nombre d'
indices qui laissent penser que si l'on
avait la possibilité est que s'il s'en
donner les moyens à travers cette
réforme constitutionnelle il se
laisserait donc la porte ouverte à un
troisième mandat
l'opposition conteste la réforme
constitutionnelle depuis le mois
d'octobre mais peut-elle vraiment faire
grand chose et sa décision de ne pas
participer aux législatives en mars ne
lui il n'y aura t'elle pas finalement
alors je crois que l'opposition déjà
fait son rôle qui est de montrer des
problèmes de légalité et compris d'un
point de vue constitutionnel
la constitution de la république de
guinée est une constitution qui marche
relativement bien mais qui n'est pas
nécessairement respecter donc se pose la
question de l'état de droit et de la
possibilité pour l'opposition également
pour la société civile de faire barrage
à un type de manoeuvre qui tendent à
personnaliser personnifier le pouvoir
donc l'opposition d'une certaine manière
est dans son rôle dans le cas de la
guinée
il faut quand même souligner que cette
opposition a été d'une certaine manière
aussi partie prenante du pouvoir et du
système
donc on est je dirais dans un jeu de
dupes dans un rapport de forces
classiques entre pouvoir et opposition
et le fait de boycotter des élections
législatives qui vont être coupés donc
un référendum fait partie aussi d'une
stratégie qui et je dirai dans l'est
ah les outils dont dispose toute
opposition alors cela peut aller
effectivement vers une forme de
pourrissement de la situation vers une
forme de blocage institutionnel et
constitutionnel
mais en même temps il faut se poser la
question de pourquoi se bat réellement
l'opposition est ce qu'on se bat
uniquement pour la question va dire du
pouvoir ou est-ce qu'on se bat pour
quelque chose qui va au delà de limiter
la question de la démocratie à des
enjeux d'alternance à des enjeux
d'élections à des enjeux de partage de
pouvoir donc il ya je dirai tout une
question beaucoup plus profonde sur
laquelle l'opposition doit être capable
de se positionner de se mobiliser et
peut-être aussi de se renouveler on est
dans des jeux politiques qui présente
les mêmes acteurs depuis un certain
temps il via de nouvelles générations
qui arrivent sur le terrain donc on voit
aussi parmi la société civile parmi
notamment les forces et des militant
panafricaniste de nouvelles envies de
voir une autre guinée arriver et donc je
pense que l'opposition doit aujourd'hui
de comprendre que certes et la une un
devoir mais en même temps aidé à une
marge de manoeuvre qui l'amène aussi à
se renouveler à repenser son logiciel et
à faire en sorte que on arrive à une
solution sachant que c'est quand même le
président le pouvoir actuel qui tient
les cartons non merci beaucoup monsieur
boukari à barra nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci encore
le 29 janvier le président guinéen alpha
condé fixe les règles du référendum
constitutionnel comportant une vingtaine
d'articles décret présidentiel porte sur
les modalités d'organisation du scrutin
les conditions de la campagne électorale
la description du processus du vote et
début février il fixe la date du
référendum au 1er mars 2020 les rumeurs
autour de la nouvelle constitution
courait depuis le début 2019 ce n'est
qu'en septembre que le président guinéen
se prononce pour la première fois en
faveur du référendum
je vous demande de vous organiser et de
vous préparer pour le référendum et les
élections
c'est cette déclaration qui a déclenché
une profonde crise politique qui
continuent à secouer le pays à partir du
mois d'octobre presque chaque semaine
des milliers de personnes protestent à
conakry et dans les capitales régionales
contre les changement de la constitution
bâtiments publics saccagés magasin
dévasté routes bloquées la contestation
est tout sauf pacifique
la police riposte par du gaz lacrymogène
des projectiles anti émeutes mais fait
aussi usage de balles réelles
un nombre d ong de défense des droits de
l'homme comme human rights watch et
amnesty international six ans la
sonnette d'alarmé dénonçant les
violences policières
à ce jour le bilan s'annonce lourd près
de 30 civils sont tués dans les
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
des centaines de personnes sont arrêtées
parmi les détenus figurent aussi des
dizaines de membres du front national
pour la défense de la constitution
le principal pilier de la mobilisation
anti condé ce mouvement né en avril 2019
suite à l'apparition des premières
rumeurs sur un changement éventuel de la
constitution composé des principaux
partis d'opposition des syndicats des
membres de la société civile
le fn décès n'a qu'un seul objectif
barrer la route à condé vers un
troisième mandat pour cela ces militants
appellent régulièrement à des
manifestations
une activité que le gouvernement
considère comme illégitime
face à l'ampleur inédite de la
contestation le président guinéen ne se
prive pas de rappeler qu'il bénéficie
lui aussi du soutien de la population
fin octobre des milliers de guinéens
inondent les rues de la capitale pour
une démonstration de force en faveur
d'alpha condé habillés aux couleurs du
parti présidentiel
les partisans de condé scandent oui à la
nouvelle constitution
un soutien dont le chef d'état aura
certainement besoin car en plus d'un
référendum constitutionnel
il se prépare activement pour les
élections législatives prévues pour le
1er mars obtenir la majorité
parlementaire et pour lui tout aussi
crucial aujourd'hui le parti
présidentiel le rassemblement du peuple
de guinée ne possède pourtant que 53
sièges
sur 113 existants pour former la
majorité il se voit donc contraint de
s'allier avec d'autres forces politiques
cette fois pourtant la tâche sera
simplifié car tous les poids lourds de
l'opposition guinéenne refuse de
participer aux élections réunis sous la
bannière du fn décès ils accusent la
commission électorale de ne pas être en
mesure d'organiser un scrutin libre et
indépendant
nous confirmons le boycott les
conditions pour une élection
transparente ne sont pas réunies ces
élections ont les empêchera selon les
médias locaux l'absence de principale
force d'opposition un risque d'avoir un
fort impact sur le taux de participation
cependant le président du pays et
n'entend pas reculer fin janvier il
entame la campagne électorale de son
parti
aucun guinéen de devra mourir de faim de
maladie et manqué d'éducation parce que
l'etat sera là pour les accompagner et
les soutenir
un objectif ambitieux que condé souhaite
réaliser en cinq ans mais réussira-t-il
car après dix ans à la tête du pays son
bilan s'annonce mitigé d'un côté il ya
des avancées importantes bitumage des
axes routiers nouvelles infrastructures
électrification de nombreuses villes
construction d'hôtels et d'immeubles
le pib du pays a augmenté d'environ 60%
pendant la présidence de condé la
croissance est presque deux fois plus
élevé que la moyenne en afrique
subsaharienne le taux de chômage lui
aussi restent parmi les plus bas de la
région pourtant la situation générale en
guinée vient ternir ce tableau
environ 60% de la population vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
l électrification du pays reste toujours
un défi de taille plus de 80% de la
population n'a pas aujourd'hui accès à
l'électricité dans les zones rurales
soto a quand même 98% le pays emprunte
aussi de plus en plus à l'étranger rien
qu'en 2019
la dette extérieure de la guinée passe
de 19 5% du pib à 29 2%
il ne faut pourtant pas oublier les
conditions difficiles dans lesquelles
condé a accédé à la présidence comment
at il pris les rênes du pays comment la
communauté internationale réagit-elle
aux événements actuels en guinée la
réponse après la pause
[Musique]
depuis octobre la guinée et le théâtre
de nombreuses manifestations contre la
réforme constitutionnelle proposée par
alpha condé à la tête du pays depuis dix
ans ce dernier semble ne pas vouloir
céder son siège présidentiel une
histoire familière dans ce pays africain
qui a connu très peu de présidents en
plus d'un demi siècle d'indépendance
ancienne colonie française la guinée
obtient son indépendance en 1958 dès
lors le pays ne connaît pas une variété
de président il est d'abord dirigé par
ahmed sékou touré qui reste au pouvoir
pendant 26 ans il a certes joué un rôle
clé dans la lutte pour l'indépendance du
pays mais il concentre le pouvoir dans
ses mains et instaure le monopartisme
sous son mandat l'opposition est
fortement réprimée à sa mort en 1984
c'est le colonel lansana conté qui
s'accaparent du pouvoir à la suite d'un
coup d'état
au début des années 1990 comptait
réintroduire le multipartisme et
organise les élections nominalement
démocratique
cependant celles-ci sont entachées par
des fraudes et une pression sur
l'opposition de la part du pouvoir
lansana conté les gaines en 1993 et
devient alors officiellement le
président légitimement élu nouvelles
élections 1998 et encore une victoire
pour conter en 2001 le président guinéen
organise un référendum afin de modifier
la constitution
cela lui permet de se représenter pour
la troisième fois en 2003 gravement
malade compte égale le scrutin avec près
de 95 % des voix car l'opposition
boycotte le scrutin compte et se
maintiendra au pouvoir jusqu'à sa mort
en 2000
profitant de cette fragilité politique
la junte militaire prend alors la tête
du pays avec comme chef de file le
capitaine dadis camara au pouvoir camara
promet d'organiser des élections
présidentielles au bout d'un an et qu
aucun militaire ne sied présentera
cependant un an après rompant avec sa
promesse initiale dadis camara annonce
vouloir se présenter aux élections
présidentielles de décembre 2009
le 28 septembre 2009 des milliers
d'opposants se réunissent dans le stade
de conakry la capitale du pays pour dire
non à la candidature de camara
ce rassemblement de l'opposition tourne
au drame 157 personnes sont tuées par
les militaires il ya 1400 blessés et une
centaine de femmes sont violées en
décembre 2009 camara est gravement
blessé suite à une tentative
d'assassinât et c'est le général sékouba
konaté qui lui succède
ce dernier organise enfin les élections
présidentielles en 2010 ces dernières
sont remportés à près de 52 % des voix
par alpha conté un ancien professeur de
droit emprisonné au début des années
2000 sous conté il est un farouche
opposant du régime militaire précédent
pourtant l'économiste et ancien premier
ministre cellou dalein diallo contestent
ces résultats dénonçant des fraudes
de violents mouvements de protestation
se répandent alors dans tout le pays la
cour suprême guinéenne reconnaît
pourtant les résultats
alpha condé devient officiellement
président le 21 décembre 2010 dès sa
prise de pouvoir condé promet aux
guinéens de faire table rase du passé
se présentant comme le mandela de la
guinée il souhaite mettre fin aux
tensions entre les différentes ethnies
qui ravageait le pays depuis la fin du
19e siècle
de plus il promet de lutter contre la
corruption et de redresser l'économie du
pays il mise sur le secteur agricole et
en particulier minier car le sous sol
guinéen est riche en bauxite et en or
les résultats ne se font pas attendre
lors de son premier mandat entre 2010 et
2015 le pib passe de 6,8 à 8,7 milliards
de dollars selon la banque mondiale et
l'inflation passe de 15,5 à 8,2 pour
cent
pourtant condé peine à établir un
gouvernement les élections législatives
initialement prévues pour 2011 ont été
reportées à plusieurs reprises et ont
été source de violences meurtrières dans
le pays entre les partisans de condé et
l'opposition
il faudra attendre deux ans pour
qu'elles aient enfin lyon alpha condé
sera reconduit à un deuxième mandat en
avec près de 57% des voix celui ci selon
la constitution devait être le dernier
cependant des mouvements de contestation
au lieu accusant condé de fraude
électorale en 2017 les tensions refont
surface le peuple guinéen déplorent
leurs conditions de vie précaires
coupures d'électricité en permanence
manque d'emplois et salaires bas de plus
s'ils ne tirent pas profit de la
richesse minière du pays
toujours la même année les guinéens
manifestent contre le report des
élections locales qui n'ont pas eu lieu
depuis 2005
face à la grogne sociale elles auront
finalement lieu en 2018
en 2019 les guinéens en prennent à
nouveau la rue lorsque condé propose de
modifier la constitution leur laissant
penser qu'il souhaite briguer un
troisième mandat pourtant peut-on
vraiment s'attendre à une
internationalisation de la crise
guinéenne
puisqu'en octobre dernier à au tout
début des manifestations les principales
diplomatie mondiale ont déjà fait savoir
leur position sur le sujet la crise
politique que traverse la république de
guinée source de préoccupation pour la
communauté internationale il est ainsi
indispensable d'organiser dans les
délais légaux des élections législatives
et présidentielle libres crédibles et
transparentes dans le respect du cadre
constitutionnel et dans un environnement
apaisé inquiétudes sur les violences et
appels à la retenue des réactions
prudentes qui pour l'essentiel n'ont pas
été actualisé depuis
face à la contestation grandissante
contre la nouvelle constitution
seule la france a récemment émis un
doute sur cette réforme controversée
c'est la situation la plus sensible
aujourd'hui et l'engagement du président
alpha condé a demandé une réforme de la
constitution ne nous paraît pas être
obligatoirement partager ni par sa
population ni par ses voisins des mots
qui touche une corde sensible en réponse
alpha condé exige du respect de la part
de l'ancien colonisateur et rappelle que
la décision finale sur la constitution
revient au peuple guinéen et c'est cette
position que choisissent d'adopter les
autres poids lourds mondiaux comme les
états unis qui évite de mettre
directement en cause le dirigeant
africain
c'est une chose de modifier sa
constitution en donnant la parole au
peuple
et en suivant un processus clair mais là
où nous avons un problème c'est quand
les dirigeants changent une constitution
uniquement pour se maintenir en place
est ce le cas aujourd'hui en guinée je
ne sais pas une prudence compréhensible
les relations entre washington et
conakry ont actuellement le vent en
poupe
la dernière visite d'alpha condé aux
états unis date de septembre dernier et
l'a d'ailleurs durer trois semaines qui
ont été bien chargé le président a
d'abord été reçu par le secrétaire
d'état mike fontenot en tête à tête
ensuite il a multiplié les déplacements
et les rencontres un peu partout aux
états unis washington boston new york
houston le tout pour promouvoir
l'industrie minière et agricole
guinéenne en voyage qui porte ses fruits
parmi les accords annoncés figurent une
ligne aérienne directe entre conakry et
les etats unis ont encore en projet
d'exploitation du gaz en guinée par les
américains washington cherche
actuellement investir plus en afrique
pour contrer l'influencé chinoise
cependant alors qu'il commence à
s'implanter en guinée il risque de se
heurter un adversaire puissant car dans
le secteur minier motrice de l'économie
guinéenne
la russie occupe déjà les meilleures
positions
la société russe d'aluminium rusal est
un des plus gros investisseur étranger
dans le pays
plus de 300 millions de dollars en 16
ans soit 6 % de tous les investissements
étrangers en guinée rues sales exploite
déjà trois gisements de bauxite dans le
pays qui alimente 25% de toute sa
production pourtant l'implantation ou
russes ne se limite pas à ça extraction
d'art travaux de construction accord de
coopération scientifique médicale et
militaire par conséquent la coopération
prospère une proximité qui ne cesse
d'inquiéter les médias en janvier 2019
une déclaration de l'ambassadeur de
russie en guinée alexandre brigadier a
défrayé la chronique guinéenne
selon 'reuters' il aurait déclaré
soutenir le changement de la
constitution et un troisième mandat pour
alpha condé provoquant évidemment l'ire
de l'opposition guinée l'ambassade de
russie a eu beau préciser que les propos
en question étaient sortis de leur
contexte
rien n'y fit l'ambassadeur est renvoyé
deux mois plus tard et aucun commentaire
portant sur la constitution guinéenne
n'a depuis été émis par moscou mais le
coup est porté le soutien présumé de la
russie au troisième mandat de condé
s'est ancré dans les titres des médias
exemple la rencontre à huis clos entre
poutine et condé à sotchi en octobre
lors du forum russie afrique est perçue
comme la confirmation de cette théorie
cette rencontre n'a pourtant rien
d'exceptionnel le président russe a
aussi reçu à huis clos
abdel fattah al-sisi par exemple
d'ailleurs certains soutien d'alpha
condé se sont manifestés dans un rayon
beaucoup plus restreint parmi eux il ya
le président malien qui déclare
ouvertement il n'est pas contre un
troisième mandat de son homologue
même si la réforme constitutionnelle
permettait cela quelques rimes hurla et
si la nouvelle constitution qui vient
lui permet ce n'est pas la volonté du
peuple guinéen qui doit compter un franc
parler qui restent rares dans la région
mais qui en dit long sur son paysage
politique
en effet au cours des vingt dernières
années par moins de onze dirigeants
africains ont ainsi fait modifier la
constitution de leur pays pour se
maintenir au pouvoir
il n'est donc pas étonnant que plusieurs
pays africains préfèrent ne pas
s'exprimer sur la réforme de la loi
fondamentale guinée depuis quelques
heures circule sur les réseaux sociaux
un message attribué au président de la
commission de la cedeao portant sur le
nombre de mandats présidentiels dont les
états membres la direction de la
communication voudrais par ce canal
apporter un démenti formel et
catégorique à ces propos pour mieux
comprendre les enjeux régionaux nous
rejoignons à nouveau hamza de boukari à
barra professeur à l'école politique
africaine de paris secrétaire général de
la ligue panafricaine humeau ja monsieur
boukari la barre à la cedeao l'union
européenne ou encore l'union africaine
reste presque indifférente face aux cris
de l'opposition guinéenne comment pouvez
vous expliquer ce silence radio
il ya plusieurs éléments déjà d'un point
de vue historique la guinée est un pays
qui a pris son indépendance en 1958 dans
une contexte dans un contexte de
souveraineté à travers la position de
sékou touré et donc je pense qu'il ya
sur le principe un attachement à l'idée
de souveraineté de la part de la guinée
l'idée de non ingérence des acteurs
étrangers dans la vie politique interne
d'autre part toutes les institutions que
vous avez cités ont leurs limites dans
le cas de la cedeao qui la communauté
des états la communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest la guinée à
travers la figure d'alpha condé a mené
des médiations dont les pays voisins
notamment au niveau de la de la gambie
par exemple et donc alpha condé s'est
posé en médiateur lui même de la
résolution de conflits en afrique de
l'ouest et j'ai l'impression qu'il est
difficile pour la cedeao qui a utilisé
alpha condé comme médiateur de taper du
poing sur la table vis-à-vis aujourd'hui
de ce qui se passe il y a eu l'an voie
d'une délégation de chefs d'état
d'anciens chefs d'état notamment le
béninois nicéphore soglo et le nigérian
goodluck jonathan qui l'avait envoyé
sous comment dire l'étiquette de
président qui s'était proprement retirer
du pouvoir qui avaient respecté leur
constitution pour tenter je dirais
d'inciter le président alpha condé a
retiré son projet de modification
constitutionnelle le président condé a
très mal perçu cette volonté d'un régime
d'ingérence de la part des dirigeants
africains qui par ailleurs ont mis en
place une sorte de forum et de chats qui
explique qu'il est important que les
chefs d'état respecte le nombre de
mandats il respecte leur constitution
mais là encore au niveau de la cie des
eaux ce ne sont finalement que des que
des paroles de bonne volonté il n'y a
pas de capacités je dirais à faire
pression sur le pouvoir guinéen
concernant l'union africaine là encore
aussi elle est effectivement très
discrète l'union africaine condamne les
chefs d'état qui arrivent au pouvoir par
des coups d'état des régimes qui
arrivent au pouvoir par des coups d'état
mais elle ne condamne pas ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les coups d'état
constitutionnels et donc là aussi il ya
une impuissance de la part de cette
institution dont alpha condé a été
président dans le cadre de la présidence
tournante
et enfin concernant l'union européenne
on sait qu'elle est ce qu'on appelle un
bailleur de fonds de la république de
guinée mais elle n'est pas non plus je
dirais en capacité de se positionner
réellement sur un conflit sur une crise
dont elle ne maîtrise peut-être pas
totalement les tenants et les
aboutissants il ya quand même une
exception c'est la france qui a mis en
doute la réforme constitutionnelle est
pourquoi la france mais partage ne
partage tel pas la retenue des autres de
ceux que nous avons évoqué la france est
l'ancienne puissance coloniale elle n'a
jamais accepté la manière dont la guinée
a pris son indépendance de fameux non de
sékou touré au général de gaulle disant
qu'il préférait la pauvreté dont la
liberté à la richesse dans l'esclavagé
et tout un boycott qui a été mise en
place ensuite par la france vis-à-vis de
la guinée donc il ya je dirais un
contentieux historique très fort et je
crois que le président condé a répondu
de manière assez sèche à jean yves le
drian qui estimait que ne peuple guinéen
n'avait pas de volonté de modification
de constitution et de maintien de son
pouvoir en place
donc il ya aussi je dirais une capacité
de 2 d'état du pouvoir guinéen à se dire
souverain nationaliste indépendant quand
cela arrange et d'autre part a continué
finalement à travailler d'un point de
vue économique avec des intérêts
français
donc il y a un jeu un jeu de dupes je
dirais à un jeu de séduction même temps
puisqu'on sait que la france suit de
très près ce qui se passe en guinée et
puis surtout toujours cette impression
que la france est en mesure de donner
des leçons qu'elle est en mesure de dire
ce que finalement les peuples africains
voudrais donc il ya quelque chose de
très problématique en sachant que alpha
condé est aussi un personnage qui dont
son parcours est très liée finalement à
l'histoire d'une certaine opposition
africaine guinéenne établie en france
basé en france c'est d'ailleurs ici en
france on a des manifestations
régulières de l'opposition et de la
société civile et de la diaspora
guinéenne par rapport à cette
problématique de troisième mandat et
d'autre part on a évidemment
tout une volonté de l'opposition de
faire en sorte que le président alpha
condé ne trouvent pas de soutien auprès
de cette ancienne puissance coloniale il
soit quelque part isolé sur la scène
internationale
merci beaucoup monsieur boukari ya
barrage le rappelle vous êtes professeur
à l'école politique africaine de paris
secrétaire général de la ligue
panafricaine imogène merci encore hamza
de boukari camara d'avoir participé à
cette émission d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rfi
[Musique]